[Music]
in 1956 a Harvard psychologist named dr.
George a Miller did a study a review for
psychological review magazine behind a
magic of numbers and he was specifically
focused on the number 7 and here's what
he came up with he realized that there
is a certain magic behind us the
audience the customer remembering seven
digits so for example he talked about
the fact that phone numbers are seven
digits in a phone number matter of fact
if you think about right now depending
on whatever generation you're part of
there used to be a time prior to having
cell phones we had to remember numbers
so most people had phone books if you
did there was a little phone pocket but
we would write all the numbers down and
then eventually if you set it enough
times you know until today I remember
phone numbers that we use twenty-five
years ago eight one eight five four
seven zero seven three now was my home
number I haven't used this number for
20-some years but these numbers stayed
right so he said people can remember
generally seven numbers so phone seven
numbers then you think about seven days
in a week
very simple seven notes to musical skill
seven card stud
seven deadly sins magnificent seven even
Roman numerals if you go down you've
seen these before where that represents
one V represents five X represents ten L
represents 50 there's names to these
unum all these other things that it goes
all the way down to seven there's a lot
of magic behind the number seven so Pat
what does this have to do title was how
easy is it to buy your product exactly
let me explain to what I mean by how
easy is it to buy your product seven
worked back in the days seven work back
in the days if I were to ask how many
phone numbers right now you know right
off the top of your head stop everything
you don't grab a piece of paper and
write down how many phone numbers you
know off the top your head with the
number seven see how many can actually
remember don't touch your phone don't
look at anything make a list
can you remember 100 can you remember 50
what is the limit you know why you
probably can't think about 50 odds are
some of you guys may but not everybody
can remember 50 because you don't have
to so whatever our brain doesn't use it
doesn't get any better so today today
I'm here to tell you the new magical
magical number for your business
as an entrepreneur to simplify make
everything easy for your customer to buy
is a number three three is the new
magical number three is a new three
primary colors is three which is what
red yellow and blue if you want to talk
about for Photoshop it's what red green
and blue I believe right but it's
typically red yellow and blue three
parts of a personality we can remember
by Sigmund Freud it which which it is
your animal instinct then you have ego
which is your personality and then the
super-ego which is your your
subconscious you can say subconscious
mind then you have three trimesters in a
pregnancy we can remember the number
three again Pat what is three have three
trimesters and business so go back to
buying your product how many steps do I
have to take to buy your product write
it out make a list of it for instance
imagine why restaurants came out with
fast food and McDonald's start a crush
on everybody why because look at the
steps here look at the steps here I'm
busy it's 5:30 or it's 6:30 in the
morning I'm going to work where it's
5:30 I'm leaving my job I'm driving I'm
hungry my wife calls me says I have
nothing ready for dinner tonight let's
just say or I'm single
there's no food I have to go buy your
food cuz I'm not a cook right or in the
morning I want to grab something I
forgot to make breakfast I want to grab
something you're driving any say and do
I want to stop over here there is no
fast but look what happens in the mind
for in your mind your mind says this I
have to park the car
turn off the car open the door take my
seatbelt off it's already warm cars
heated it's cold outside I have to step
outside in the cold and maybe raining
it's not warm I have to go inside stand
in line with four people ahead of me
everybody's trying to order coffee place
my order go wait for this person and
then get back and turn on the car put
everything in the car all the same
process I need to go through then I go
to work the mind says no I'm not doing
I'm going straight to work McDonald's
said no here's all I need to do combine
and wait there's five cars ahead of you
place your order make your payment pick
up your food one two three simple fast
food became a phenomenon they got thirty
five thousand McDonald's now around the
world very simple one two three one two
you got Amazon very simple what do you
want click on it if you're Prime member
well boom boom simple process three-step
process the companies I tell you that
have this easiest process of selling a
product to client typically can scale
the most because it's very easy to do so
again going back to the question I asked
you take your product I'm a customer I
want to buy your product what do I need
to go through okay make a list is it ten
steps eleven steps seventeen steps five
steps six steps and however many steps
it is see if you can eliminate it and
bring it down to three steps see what
you can take out you know you know we
don't need this I don't know why we even
added this over here oh you know we
don't need this we need like in the
insurance world right now in the
insurance world myself and I went to one
of the biggest reinsurance companies
because I have a proposal of what I want
to do for the life insurance industry
and it's got a lot of attention
everybody's calling me saying hey Pat we
want to possibly put a couple hundred
million dollars into this idea that you
have and we want to see if we can make
your work what is it my idea is very
simple there's many process of it I'm
trying to take out that is not necessary
purely not necessary and it's getting
investors attention that want to back
this up that we can go from seven steps
to buying the products of or five steps
to buying a product to all of a sudden
three steps to buying a product right
now for the longest time insurance
required so many steps to buying a
product we have a product right now that
we're selling that simply requires three
steps one two three we sold more of that
policy than anybody else in the world
including US Canada and UK and the
company is flabbergasted but it's
because they have the easiest process of
selling the product it's one two three
and customers today Millennials Gen X's
gen Y's gravitate towards an easier
sales process because back in the days
it was seven today it is three and why
is it three let me tell you why these
three and why you ought to pay attention
to this talk about how much is being fed
in our minds today talk about how much
is being fed in our minds today think
about how many YouTube videos we watch
per day think about how many Facebook
newsfeed you watch a video another video
another video these are all images
that's requiring energy your brain is
burning calories to watch these images
this color these emotions all this stuff
that you're seeing
is sucking up all the data for you to
restore information right it's just
taking it taking and taking and take
anything we can do seven we can do three
very simple by the way don't try to
fight us like gravity don't say I'm
going to try to change the law of
gravity not going to happen I'm gonna
try to change our law of familiar you're
not going to happen I'm gonna try to
change some of these lots not going to
happen
so don't find it adjust a damn and try
to figure out a way how we can make it
easy for people to buy your product
within your company now with that being
said then it's let's get this pillow out
here we are I think two weeks away from
choosing one of our pillows we're still
getting pillow sent over our way but if
you have a subscribe to this channel
please do so click on the button here to
subscribe to the channel by the way
again I think YouTube's got a new thing
where you can subscribe one and those
email you some of the episodes or to
click on the alert right next to
subscribe it's like an alarm button and
you actually get notified immediately
any videos that comes at you become on
the first two watching value taming
videos you can comment on it but if you
haven't subscribed please do so our goal
is to take this channel to million subs
by the end of 2017 just a year ago we
were at five thousand subs today we're
at one hundred fifty five thousand subs
and we like to take this 2 million subs
by the end of 2017 and we feel with your
help we can do this because we believe
we are the number one how to channel for
entrepreneurs on YouTube and we talk
about things that you can actually
implement and to help and grow your
business not just a bunch of motivation
and regurgitating the same old content
over and over again we want to bring
your new content that helps you grow
your business and if you have any
questions or thoughts please comment on
the bottom take everybody by
[Music]
you